[Musique]
dans notre chu on a grossièrement elle
preuve une progression de 10% à peu près
des des hospitalisations et avec les
réanimations qui vont avec un fatalement
mais c'est pas non plus c'est que 10%
donc on peut voir les choses comme on
commet comme on veut c'est vrai que si
ces dispenses ans toutes les semaines
s'il va y avoir un problème mais il faut
avoir ça en tête dans l'idée d'une
responsabilité de chacun c'est à dire
que les cas ne tombe pas du ciel
les cas ce sont des personnes qui
transmettent à des personnes dont on a
les moyens tous chacun moi vous no no no
no proche d' agir là dessus
et si on veut me l'invité un confinement
est bien ma foi il faut faire ce qu'il
faut c'est à dire avoir avoir des gestes
barrières respecter tout simplement
l'idée générale elle est pas de se dire
est ce qu'on va confiné mais plutôt il
faut essayer de faire en sorte d'éviter
le confinement à tout prix il ya
beaucoup de gens qui souffrent du
confinement l'économie souffre du
confinement et donc il faut essayer de
faire en sorte et c'est un petit peu le
sens de l' oms qui vous dit c'est
vraiment larmes de dernière où il faut
faire attention à l'idée selon laquelle
l'épidémie flamberait parce que les
français seraient peu ou prou
irresponsable parce que ça je suis pas
sûr que ce soit un discours qui
aujourd'hui après un an de sacrifices
soient vraiment audible
je comprends mais évidemment le
sentiment de lassitude
ce sentiment de peut-être pas eu de
révolte qui qui qui pointe son nez il
faut que le gouvernement il soit
sensible mais en tout cas moi je veux
dire les restaurateurs qui sont chez moi
par exemple et qui ont dit on va ouvrir
systématiquement et de manière constante
j'ai dit non non parce que c'est une
violation de la loi et que peut pas
faire ça on ne fait pas ça au contest
via les voies de droit mais jamais et à
aucun moment on ne vient violé la loi ce
qui a dernier mot je leur ai dit parce
que c'est vraiment important à mes yeux
te dire comme quoi saisir le juge n'est
pas un acte de anti gouvernement c'est
un acte qui permet d'éviter une révolte
et parce que c'est la révolte légitime
finalement de saisir un juge ses seins
de saisir un juge
il faut que les gens qui pensent à
plutôt que deux à désobéir dont je me
des confinerait je me confie n'aurait
pas d'abord il ya quand même attention
parce que quand un virus qui circulent
ne faut pas non plus perdre de vue mais
sur le plan juridique c'est une
violation de la loi
c'est une mise en danger de la vie
d'autrui c'est pas possible de faire ce
à dire que les gens qui sont
hospitalisés et il a fort quand ils sont
hospitalisés et holly de lille ne se met
pas en opposition un confinement qui
aurait pu leur éviter d'être là donc non
ça on ne constate pas mais c'est une
population sélectionné bien entendu ceux
qui peuvent se permettre d'être content
c'est ceux qui n'ont rien et qui sont
pas malades
après on peut le comprendre on peut le
comprendre parce que c'est une
frustration pour tout le monde c'est
même à un problème économique pour
beaucoup c'est un problème psychologique
pour un pour un grand nombre mais en
face il faut mettre des réalités la
réalité c'est 70 mille soixante dix
mille morts c'est pas rien c'est si on
veut le l'illustré encore un petit peu
mieux
c'est un airbus qui se crashe tous les
jours c'est ça la réalité donc enfin
s'il faut mettre effectivement des
choses approprié
c'est évident mais c'est pour éviter ce
genre de catastrophe humaine que nous
subissons des contraintes
[Musique]
j'espère qu'il ne sera pas indispensable
parce que ça voudrait dire qu'on a pu
l'éviter maintenant c'est un outil qui
marche face est incontestable ça marche
donc si il faut l'utiliser il faudra
l'utiliser mais la vraie solution c'est
pas du tout les confinements parce que
déconfinement on peut en faire 10 may 30
il y aura toujours une circulation des
russes la vraie solution c'est le mc5 et
c'est tout il y en a pas d'autre puisque
de toute façon pour l'instant il n'y a
pas de traitement le virus ne sera
jamais éradiqué l'idée générale si vous
voulez c'est de réussir à trouver un
équilibre
il va falloir avoir un équilibre qui
permettent finalement de préserver
d'abord une vie la plus normale possible
pour en arriver à une vie normale
là où il faut faire attention si mais le
juriste n'a toujours faire attention à
ce que l'urgence médicale sanitaire ne
soit jamais une rupture du principe de
proportionnalité
quant à l'atteinte aux libertés dire
qu'il ne faudrait pas se dire bon on a
eu d'épidémie elle est là elle est là de
toute façon pour un moment et donc ça
justifie forcément et nécessairement
presque un certain nombre d'atteintes
aux libertés sans que nous ayons à
vérifier la proportionnalité ça ce
serait la pire des choses
[Musique]